[Music]
how are you guys doing i recently
watched a video from russell brand
an english comedian and activist who was
talking about the palestine
israel issue so let's see what he has to
say
and come back and talk about this really
when you're saying do a video you're
saying take a side
take aside then i think you're part of
the problem you're part of the problem
because in a way what side is
there is for me this these are the two
sides ongoing conflict
solution and like i would if there were
a side labeled
solution then i would be on that side as
we can see here with this
brand takes a pragmatic approach you can
say he says if there was a side
name solution i would be on that side
and what i found really to be honest
disappointing
i have to say because russell brand is
someone who's usually quite
open and honest doesn't care what people
have to say is well known in the past to
have taken controversial opinions
and you know and we've respected him i
think as
the british public for so doing in
particular i think the muslim community
have respected him as well because of
his sympathetic
kind of approach uh to us and we we we
notice those things we have to say we
notice
those um people who are sympathetic and
open
minded to us from those who are
who imbue animosity and
and and those kinds of characteristics
so that
having been said let's say now that when
he says
if you ask me or i'm paraphrasing here
to take a side then you're part of the
problem
i think that's absolutely false and to
be quite honest with you i don't think
that would be his stance
on many of the historical injustices
that have happened to so many different
peoples
the aborigines the native americans the
south africans
the apartheid state of south africa if
we had to ask
russell brand what is your uh opinion
on the racial apart racist apartheid
that took place in south africa i think
you'll be very open
and take a side straight away on these
issues to be honest with you
uh but what is really much different
here what you what are we talking about
if you're asking me to take a side then
you're part of the problem but you you
take sides all the time with all due
respect
it's not as if you don't take sides it's
not as if i if i did a data analysis
of your body of work that you haven't
taken very clear and decisive
political and historical sides if you
want to put it that way
what do you mean don't take aside and if
you ask me to take aside your part of
the problem
this is a kind of deflection mechanism
this is a kind of
uh way you're trying to kind of absorb
yourself from a controversy which to be
quite honest with you
is not like you you're usually quite
brave and forthright and open and honest
on these issues so i have to say i am
totally disappointed especially
considering the fact
that this case is so clear we are
talking about
we are talking about a so-called state
that after its inception in 1948
has literally quote unquote in its words
of its uh
of his uh president today conquered land
he even spoke about conqueror in gaza if
i were to
if i were to ask you about isis if i
were to ask you about the conquering of
land
that isis committed which is
antithetical to un treaties and
international law
i think you'd be quite honest and open
and say oh well this is an abomination
this is abominable this is condemnable
this is monstrous
and you would take a side straight away
if i were to ask you about
many different kinds of injustices you
take a side straight away as i've just
mentioned
but why on this do we allow
a state a so-called state of israel
to literally take land literally this is
what they're doing
they aren't be very clear let me be very
clear
the parts in which they are in control
some parts
which they are in control according to
international community
they don't have rights too east
jerusalem they don't have rights to that
land
they are not considered by the
international community or u.n law
as being the country in charge of east
jerusalem
they are occupiers according to the un
and they in all hypocrisy claim to
believe in international law
but the un an organization which was
responsible for
for for giving this so-called state
legitimacy in the first place
the un is a is a is an organization
which condemns
and calls this an occupying force
amnesty international many organizations
which you've been associated with in the
past were quoted in the past
or i'm sure respect their work have said
the same thing human rights watch
have said the same thing
the premise that if if we're not going
to find a solution that i'm going to
remain i'm going to remain
silent on the matter or i'm going to not
take aside
is number one it's not consistent with
what you've done in other issues
that must be on the record and number
two quite frankly
is not even a logical way of dealing
with
injustice why should just because
justice is not something which is let's
say uh practical in the in
in real time today if if justice is
inaccessible to us or otherwise uh not
retrievable in the current times does
that mean to say that we we will stay
silent on the matter
anything must be productive otherwise it
should not be said
and when we say productive we're talking
about political and historical
historically
uh politically productive that's really
it seems like a false premise to me
so i think in summary i would say
russell brand
to be honest i'm very disappointed i'm
very disappointed with you i'm not
trying i'm not sure who you're trying to
appease
with this but this is not like you to be
um to be honest with you walking on
eggshells in this manner
and not taking a stance i encourage you
to change your tone on this issue i hope
you will come to your senses
you